AI is here to stay and if you want to
keep up in the creative writing world
you need to know how to use it
thankfully there are already a lot of
tools that make the AI writing process
so much easier and so in this video
we're going to go through all of
[Music]
those now I've divided these tools into
two distinct categories we have the
specialized tools that are specifically
geared to write long form fiction or
non-fiction and then we have the chat
box Bots which are kind of a catch-all
for everything else and generally
speaking I recommend that authors have
one in each category so one of the
specialized tools and one of the chat
Bots to be a catchall for any other
thing that doesn't quite fall into the
realm of fiction writing specifically
but might just be something you need
maybe you need to brainstorm something
maybe you need to do a book description
something that isn't necessarily as easy
to do in the specialized tools because
they're not designed for it but the
specialized tools are also really
helpful because they dramatically
simplify the fiction writing process and
so in this video we're going to go
through both of those categories
starting with the chat Bots and then
we'll get into the specialized tools
later so let's start with the chat Bots
the chat Bots can basically all be used
for fiction although they are more
versatile than that and most of them
specialize in one particular family of
models so you have the cloud models the
gbt models the Llama models Etc now this
video is not going to go in depth on the
Which models are better because number
number one they're all pretty good now
and number two I'm actually going to do
a separate video comparing all of the
different large language models to each
other instead in this video we're going
to be focusing on the individual
features of each chatbot so the first
one is of course the most obvious one
that everyone knows and that is chat gbt
chat GPT I think has the distinction of
not only being first but I think it has
the most features as a chatbot now if
you go with this chatbot I do recommend
the $20 subscription there is a $200
subscription as well but that's really
only for people and businesses that are
really heavily into Ai and need that
unlimited flexibility that they get with
that plan for most authors it's going to
be wildly unnecessary chat GPT is the
chatbot that houses the GPT models from
open AI so if you go up here at the top
you can see that you've got your
different models right here it doesn't
have all of the models that GPT has ever
produced but it does have the ones
you're most likely to need including GPT
40 this is the most recent one with the
creative writing update which is one I
recommend in most cases but they also
have 01 which is a highly useful tool as
well for any kind of advanced reasoning
that you might need and it's so far the
best model that we have for editing you
also have a couple of older models here
as well Additionally you can create a
project here so if you had a project
here that we can just say um a writing
fiction project and you open up this
project here you can add Specific
Instructions for this particular project
and you can also add files so say world
World building files uh character
profile details and stuff that can all
go here and then you you can just chat
in this project and it will have all of
that stuff aware in its context about
how that works and then you can also
create gpts now gpts are actually very
similar to projects but they can be
shared with other people and they do
very specific things so to do that you
come here to create a GPT and put in the
name the description of the GPT the
instructions on what it should do this
is very similar to those instructions
that you saw in the projects section and
then you can add any particular
knowledge here so it's very similar I
wouldn't actually be surprised if they
merged these two features at some point
in the future but there is a nice thing
about a GPT is that you can share it and
use other gpts that other people have
created that's a very useful tool you
can also make sure it has access to all
of these things web search uh Dolly
image generation code interpreter and
data analysis Etc speaking of dolly
dolly is another image generating tool
that you have access to inside a chat
GPT it's probably not my favorite in
fact I'd say it's a little bit behind
but I'm sure we're going to get an
updated model pretty soon but you know
you have access to that if you need some
image generation right in the chat not
all of the chat Bots have image
generation involved additionally like
most of these chat Bots you'll have the
ability to attach files so you can add
images PDFs Etc that you want it to look
at you can also have it search the web
which is a useful feature the search GPT
functions are very useful and in fact I
don't use this particular tool but I use
another tool called perplexity which is
great for research and definitely one I
recommend additionally one of my
favorite Tools in chat gbt is the
advanced voice mode this is my go-to
place to just have back and forth
brainstorming conversations to kind of
just think through the stories that I'm
developing and stuff like that that's
one of my favorite features
unfortunately you don't get a lot of
advanced voice mode time if you are just
on the $20 plan you get an unlimited I
believe it's unlimited amount if you're
on the $200 plan but un fortunately you
only get like 15 minutes of spoken voice
if you're on the $20 plan which can run
out quickly if you use it a lot last but
not least I want to mention that chat
gbt does have the ability to customize
instructions that are kind of
universally seen across all of the
different chats so if you want it to
know certain details about yourself or
your projects or whatever it is uh you
can have it know that information at all
times essentially by including that here
in the customized GPT section but yeah
that's pretty much all of the major
features inside of chat G PT so let's
move on to the next one which is Gemini
now Gemini comes from Google and
alphabet basically and it is another one
of the top chat Bots out there I would
give it points for being the best one
with the best ecosystem now the models
have been known to be really good for
things like brainstorming and things
like that but all in all it can do all
of the same things that chaty BT or
Claud or any of the others can do you
can create what they call a gem which
has the same features essentially as the
projects or the gpts where you just give
it information about your project and
then it'll understand those things
intuitively you have access to a bunch
of different models here including 1.5
Pro and so forth and in fact if you have
Gemini Advanced which again is $20 for
the monthly tier a lot of these are
going to be $20 integrates with
everything in fact you probably even if
you don't have the advanced version you
might see it in Google Docs and other
things where it's just seamlessly
integrated into those tools that Google
has you can have it connect to YouTube
YouTube music I'm actually going to turn
that one on Google Maps Google flights
if you wanted to help you book flights
which I don't know if you really would
want to do that but uh you could do that
as well as all of your Google workspace
so it's definitely got the advantage
when it comes to interface integration
additionally Gemini has an option here
called Deep research which I actually
find to be really really useful it's
similar to chat gbt's 01 model which
does reasoning except in this case
Google will actually go out and research
the web heavily and then take all of
that information into account to give
you a definitive answer and it's a
really great thing if you want some like
definitive answers to questions and
research if you're trying to learn
something that you can get I was using
it recently to troubleshoot some issues
I was having with some games crashing
and it did a massive amount of research
and then created this sort of summarized
report on it and it was actually really
helpful so that's one of the advantages
of Gemini one of the other things I
really like about Gemini is when you
sign up for the $20 a month tier you
automatically with that get 2 terab of
storage in Google's Cloud as a business
owner I would almost pay that anyway
even without Gemini I would want that
Google cloud storage and so if you are
someone that uses Google Cloud heavily
Gemini might be one for you so that's
Gemini let's move on to Claude now
Claude is another one it's actually my
personal favorite chatbot I would give
it points for being the best minimalist
chatbot out there you can see the design
here is really simple there's not much
to it but the downside of this is it
doesn't have as many features as chat
GPT or Gemini but it does have a couple
of things that I like first of all the
models are some of my favorites I know I
said I wouldn't compare the models in
this video but they are in general the
Claude family of models are one of my
favorites and I also just like the
Simplicity of this chatbot one of the
reasons why I suggest having a chat pot
as opposed to going directly through an
API is simply Simplicity it's just
easier to pull up a chat pot and just
say a few words and it goes off and and
does its thing if I'm accessing these
models through an API like open AI
playground there's a little bit more
fine-tune control and things that you
can have there sometimes it's a better
option that doesn't have all of the
features that you get from the chat Bots
but usually you get more control you get
a little bit more technical Hands-On
approach in the apis but when you come
to the actual chat bot sometimes it's
just easier and that's why I recommend
it especially because if you are an
author that doesn't have a lot of tech
savviness just going with the chat bot
is often the best way to go and so
Claude is one of those that that's
particularly simple and I like it
because of that uh you can select your
models here when you're going through
your chat you can also and this is
something that not all of the others do
you can select whether you want concise
answers explanatory formal action Pros
oh no wait that that's one that I
created myself never mind so you can
actually create styles that are designed
to more like how you want to see it go
so you can have specific Styles set up
it's a little bit like having the custom
instructions that I showed you with chat
GPT but you can have multiple of them
and just switch through them here
generally I leave this on concise unless
I'm doing something like writing pros
and I want that available so you can do
that here you can also access projects
in Claude in fact Claude did the
projects thing first and here are some
of my projects that I have here and
these work exactly like the ones I
showed you in chat GPT except chat GPT
sort of copied what Claude was doing
because Claude had this first so you
click on any of these projects and then
you can chat within this project you've
got project knowledge here you can add
files Etc and uh it does a really good
job and it's my favorite way to interact
with the AI through a chatbot is through
a project like this and particularly in
Claude projects cuz it's nice and simple
but unfortunately that is kind of it for
the major features that Claude offers
you can attach files it does integrate
with Google Drive so you can pull in a
Google doc if you want to you can also
capture screenshots so you can ask
questions about things that you're
seeing on your screen but in general it
doesn't do things like generate images
or anything like that that some of the
others do so it is a simple one but it
is still my favorite mostly because of
the models in it but also because of the
minimalist aspect to it I just find it
really simple and easy to use so it's
all often the one that I just sort of
default to if I just need a quick answer
for something all right those are the
three biggest ones that you're probably
familiar with but I want to talk about
some others that you might not have
heard of and the first one here is
mistral's chat now mistol is one of
those models and companies that is a
little overlooked in my opinion first of
all the models are pretty good and they
might not be quite at the same level as
open AI or Claude but they will allow
for some not safe for work content if
you write that sort of content and the
chat feature is a little bit underrated
in my opinion because first of all it's
free you can use this chat for free and
it has access to some of the things that
you would get in chat GPT or the others
like canvas it does web search it also
does image generation which the images
are actually not too bad if I select
that and say give me an image of a nerdy
kn no IST and here we have a nerdy
novelist of course cuz he's got the
tousled hair and the glasses on but you
can see the quality the image generation
here is pretty good I think it might be
using flux or one of those others open
source ones and it's actually decent and
I would say this is even better than
what I could get out of Dolly in chat
GPT so that's really great now this is a
pretty simple interface and there aren't
a few features that you would expect to
find elsewhere there's no advanced voice
mode there's no projects feature so it's
just a simple chat but it is free the
models are decent it can do not sa for
work stuff and so it's an all-around
good chat tool I think most people like
many people are overlooking it I think
more people should take it seriously and
speaking a free there's one other free
chat bot that I should highlight and
that's meta now meta has their own chat
bot and it also does a lot of things
it's very similar to the mistal
interface there's no projects or
anything like that but because this is
coming from meta there are a lot of
things involved that can make it really
appropriate for certain use cases for
instance I think it's really good for
social media content and things like
that which makes sense right uh but this
is using meta's llama models and it also
has image generation so for instance
let's just say give me an image of a
nerdy novelist let's see what it gives
us it's given us four different options
instead of one like mistl did okay gave
us very similar images not quite as high
quality I'd say let's go with this one
one of the things you can do that I
really like is you can actually select
this icon right here and say animate it
is all it does is it just animates it in
a just a short little almost like a gif
type thing where it just gives it a
little bit of motion and it actually is
pretty decent it's only a couple of
seconds but as you can see here it's
giving me a little animation of the
image and it's not a bad animation too
so I think this is actually pretty good
and I really like stuff like this it
could be absolutely wonderful for social
media content and stuff like that so I
definitely still recommend you take meta
AI seriously now when it comes to
writing and things like that I don't use
it too much for fiction but it can have
a lot of other use cases that should
definitely be cons considered and it
also doesn't have any of the projects or
many of the other features that you get
in the other chat Bots but it does have
the ability to attach files and generate
images and other things like that so
it's a useful tool all right those are
all of the chat Bots that are
specifically around one particular
ecosystem of models I want to now go to
two other options that you should know
about one is very important and that
kind of use multiple different models
the first one is po now PO is a $20
subscription just like any of these chat
Bots that I've talked to so far other
than mistl and meta which are free but
the nice thing about PO is that it
actually can access any of the models
that you want pretty much all of the
ones that you would most likely use you
can access in here and you can not only
access those but you can access image
generating models as well including
idiogram including a stable diffusion
and flux and even some video generating
models in there as well now here's the
caveat you might ask like oh well then
why isn't everybody using this one
because it sounds like the best one cuz
it giv the most flexibility the problem
with PO is that from all the research
I've done they really limit the
responses and the input that you're
allowed to do so even though a model is
capable of handling really large prompts
of like tens of thousands of words po
will not allow you to do that kind of
prompting because it is trying to save
cost you know it can only do so much
when it's offering you $20 a month to
have all of these things so you're
limited in what you can do and for that
reason I wouldn't use it for any kind of
long for fiction writing it's just not
really designed for that sort of use
case because you're generating lots of
text you're inputting a lot of text it's
just clunky for that sort of use case
however if you are someone that isn't
planning on using AI too heavily in any
particular area you just want the
capability to access multiple options
when and if you need them then PO is a
really really good option because it
gives you quite a bit of access to a lot
of different models and AI video and
images and audio all within one place
and it's really useful for that kind of
use case so if you're not going to be
pushing these models too heavily you're
just going to be you know asking
questions now and then maybe trying to
get different opinions from different
models then po might be a good one to go
with now another one that is very
similar to PO but is more pay as you go
rather than a $20 subscription fee is
open router now open router is
definitely one you're going to want to
get anyway and the reason for this is cu
we're going to use it to plug into some
of the specialist tools I'll talk about
later but open router is also very
flexible in the sense that it has access
to pretty much all the models that you
could possibly want and I actually use
it as a chatbot sometimes especially if
I want to compare responses between two
different models here inside of the chat
interface I can come over here and say
add a model and as you can see we've got
tons and tons and tons of different
models available to us and we can use
any of them and this is even more models
for each ecosystem so I can go back much
older versions of Claude or GPT that I
can't do inside of chat GPT or Claud Pro
Additionally you can add files here if
you need to and you can create a new
room here which acts very similarly to
how you would use a project because you
can come here to any of these models
let's just say we're going to try deep
seek and from here you can give it a
specific system prompt so this is
similar to the custom instructions open
router is essentially a advanced API and
remember I said apis are not as simple
as the chat Bots and that's true but I
need to make sure I talk about open
router CU we're going to use it later on
but you can put system prompts in here
to add those custom instructions for
each thing and you also get quite a bit
more flexibility with this model where
you can actually adjust like what's the
temperature of the model and things like
that so if that's the kind of thing
that's important to you then you have
access to all of those things that you
can experiment with so it is a more
advanced product and it's not as simple
as the other chat Bots but it is
something that you're going to want to
know so I found myself using open router
just inside of open router not even
connected to the other tools that we're
going to talk about quite frequently
because it allows me to access all of
those models and have that flexibility
and it's pay as you go and generally
speaking I know pay as you go sounds a
little bit hesitant to people because
they're like well don't I get unlimited
chats if I'm using this $20 a month
subscription and the answer is no you
get throttled in those $20 subscriptions
there's only so much you can do they do
not let you chat indefinitely and in
fact you would probably get more chat
and more responses out of open router
for $20 than you would in a month using
Claud or or chbt or any of those others
that's because for most models the price
of creating a book inside of open router
is really simple and really inexpensive
so I'll give you an example so let's
look at the GPT model the most advanced
GPT model here this is another thing
that you can do in open router that's
very nice is you can see all of this
information about every model model the
output is $10 per million tokens of
output which means that translates to
approximately
750,000 words so unless you're
generating twice that which would be 1.5
million words in a month you're not
going to be spending more than $20 so
that's just to put in perspective that
sometimes paying as you go is actually
better because you're only going to pay
for the words that you actually use and
it's really not a whole lot of uh money
all right those are all the chat Bots
that I wanted to cover and if you want a
specific recommendation it's really
going to depend on you but my top
recommendation would be to pick one of
the big three that's chat gbt Claude and
Gemini any one of them are good again my
personal favorite is Claude but I can
definitely see how chat GPT or Gemini
might be a better option and then you of
course have mistl and llama as free
options if you want to check those out
as well or po if you're one of those
people that don't plan on using AI that
much but you want a access to as many
options as possible PO is a good option
there and then open router is just
something I mentioned because we're
going to need it going forward so now
let's talk about the specialist tools
there's three of them and yes I really
only recommend one of these three if
you're writing fiction which is nice
because that narrows down the options a
little bit there really isn't another
option out there that comes close to be
able to do what these three do or if
they do they're just poor clones of
these three so let's talk about them the
first one is novel crafter now novel is
my personal favorite however if you are
a beginning author it can be a little
bit difficult to wrap your mind around
it's a little bit more Tech heavy
there's a learning curve and it's kind
of the Adobe Photoshop of this batch
that we're about to talk about but it is
super powerful so when I'm in novel
crafter you have a bunch of options here
you can see plan you can write you have
a chat feature which is similar to
having its own chat bot so theoretically
you could have all of your words here
just right inside of the the chat bot
rather than using a different chat
instead you're still paying for those
words as you go so I generally recommend
having one of each there's just a
Simplicity to a chat bot that you don't
get with this version of the chat but
it's useful to have because you can pull
in information from your book now one of
the things I like about novel Crafters
they have this thing called the Codex
and the Codex allows you to put
information about different characters
and things like that and then when you
go to write the book you can see it's
sort of highlighted here that means it
is pulling information about that
character into the prompt so that when
it is writing this chunk of the scene it
automatically knows information about
that character so it can write them
appropriately and this is the greatest
thing about novel crafter is that it
makes it so easy to pull in all of this
information into its prompts so that the
AI knows what to write next if you're
using a chatbot to write long form
fiction you have to manually copy and
paste all of your character information
and all of that into every single prompt
to do it well whereas novel crafter will
simplify the process and just
automatically pull everything in
additionally you can access multiple
models inside of Novel crafter so if I
went here to generate pros and selected
a prompt here you can see I have access
to a bunch of different models here that
I can choose from and that is because
novel crafter is one of those tools that
is connected to open router you have to
start with a connection to open router
in order to get the large language
models to generate inside of Novel
crafter you can think of the large
language models that are supplied by
open router as the electricity and novel
crafter is kind of the appliance that
runs on the electric it if that makes
sense so not only can you pull in
characters you can put in locations and
and there's just a lot that we could
talk about novel crafter but suffice it
to say I believe it is the best tool
here in terms of harnessing the power of
AI in multiple ways and you don't even
need to use it for fiction necessarily
it can also be used for non-fiction
because it's just best for long form
writing in general it's also used pretty
heavily by people who are into like
Adventure tabletop gaming and stuff like
that because you can put all of the
information about your world and your
characters including their you know data
sheets and everything like that into the
Codex and then it automatically knows
all of those things as you're going
through and writing some text here so
you can have it you know write the next
part of your campaign or something like
that knowing all of that information and
so it's just a really good tool to sort
of organize all of the information that
you have about your world and your story
and pulling that all together and I find
that the workflow inside of Novel
crafter is the most realistic workflow
of all of them for most authors who are
doing this let's talk about the price of
Novel crafter the one I generally
recommend is the Artisan tier this gives
you access to all of the features
basically and including the chat
features if you're not as keen on the
chat features inside of Novel crafter
you can absolutely go with the hobbyist
one here and this may actually be better
if you have a separate chatbot
subscription then you might not need the
chat features inside of Novel crafter so
you can just go with the hobbyist tier
here also keep in mind that this does
not cover the amount of AI words that
you're going to generate because
remember those are coming through open
router and being channeled through novel
crafter but as I kind of informed you
already it takes quite a bit of writing
to actually spend a whole lot of money
inside of open router you have to you
know $10 using GPT 40's you know one of
their Flagship models right will get you
$750,000 words and so it's very unlikely
that on a given month you're going to be
spending more than the $20 that you
would on on the chat Bots even if you're
paying for the Artisan or the hobbyist
tier here on top of that it's very
unlikely you're going to be spending
more than $20 a month but I would
probably if you're using novel crafter
heavily let's say you're on the $14 a
month plan if you're using novel crafter
heavily and using up a lot of words
through open router you're likely to be
spending probably somewhere between $ 20
and $30 that's only if you're using it
heavily though now that leads me to the
second of the three which is called PSE
sudoite now PSE sudoite it's the one
that's been around for the longest it
was the big dog in town and now maybe
not as much of a favorite for me however
there is one redeeming quality that I'll
get to in a second but it has very
similar features to novel crafter you
can come here to this chapter and if you
want to continue writing here you just
come here and say write and then you
write what you want it to continue
writing at this stage you also have the
ability to add in all of the information
about your world including brain dum
genre the style the synopsis the
characters are all inputed here very
similar to the codec in novel crafter
you can also put your outline In Here
Also something you can do a novel
crafter so it's very similar in a lot of
ways I do think that PSE sudoite tries
to be a simpler option which is great
for authors who are not techsavvy and uh
who want something that's a little bit
simpler and easier to do that does come
with some drawbacks for instance you
cannot access all of the models that you
can inside of open router or novel
crafter via open router just because it
it just doesn't have that option which
means sometimes if there's a newer model
out you have to wait for PSE sudoite to
actually go through and determine
whether or not that model should be
included inside of PSE sudoite and then
you have to wait for them to include it
and it's a whole Hassle and if you want
to just start writing with it then you
can only use novel crafter for something
like that or the next one that I'll talk
about which also connects to open router
so there's some drawbacks there and also
the other thing I don't like about pseud
right is its pricing structure it's the
most expensive of the bunch and includes
the AI words in that subscription
meaning you're not paying as you go like
you would with novel crafter being
hooked up to open router now sudoite
does have one major redeeming quality
that I want to talk about here now as
I'm recording this this feature is in
beta uh but I believe it's going to be
opened up to to open Beta very soon so
you may see this already by the time I
talk about it but PSE sudoite has their
own model that is specifically designed
for writing fiction and this is by far
the biggest Advantage I've ever seen
them come up with cuz in terms of their
pricing structure and everything it's
not my favorite and even their interface
is not really my favorite I find novel
crafter to be a much better workflow for
myself but that said the model that
pudaite has is fantastic I'll just show
you a little bit of what that looks like
I can just come here say guided right
and it's currently designed right now so
it's using their custom model uh let's
say Mina
decides that she is actually
Cinderella and tells Jonathan about it
and this is going to write 250 words
approximately so it comes over here
writes the words out here so I've given
it kind of a ridiculous prompt right and
if I were using any of the other AI
models it would be kind of abrupt and
not great it actually hasn't gotten to
the Cinderella bit yet and sometimes it
does that because it knows that there
needs to be some some trans to get to
something so abrupt and so you know we
have Mina he said softly were you
successful she thought of the older
vampire's cold blue eyes of her taunting
words no she admitted but I have learned
something important she paused drawing
in a breath she did not need we are out
of our depth Arthur stood and adjusted
his waist coat we have faced worse Meer
remember remember that we had van Hing
then she interrupted more sharply than
she intended and now we're alone a heavy
silence settled over the room they all
knew it was true without van hing's
guidance they were navigating blind so I
found that this model is by far the best
thing that I've seen when it comes to
writing with AI it sounds the most
natural it understands the logic of a
scene much much better than any of the
AI models out there and it's also pretty
good at its pros it's not perfect but
it's going to get you more like 80% of
the way there rather than the 50% of the
way there that you might get with the
other uh chat models and so I think this
is pseudo right's biggest advantage and
if I had to recommend how to use pite I
would recommend using a different tool
for most of the work you're going to do
but then when it comes to actually
writing Pros if you want to use AI for
writing Pros that's another caveat there
you might not want to use AI for the
actual Pros writing I would only use
pseudo right for writing the pros
because it's really good at that but
then I would use some other tool for
everything else for developing the
characters and managing everything all
of that all right that brings me to the
third and last specialist tool and that
is Raptor right now Raptor right again
kind of similar to novel crafter but
much simpler and it has the added
benefit that it is free other than the
AI words that you're going to generated
so notice down here in the corner it
says open router API key this is where
you put in your API key that you get
inside of open router and it
automatically connects open router to
Raptor right just the same way as you
would in novel crafter what that means
is that any words you generate here in
Raptor you'll still have to pay for
those through open router but once again
you're not going to be paying a whole
lot of money depending on the model
you're using and so that's not really
something to worry about and unlike
novel crafter Raptor right is free so
that $8 a month or the $14 a month that
you would be paying on top of your words
in open router if you were using novel
crafter you don't have to pay those if
you're using Raptor Rite but Raptor Rite
is a lot simpler it's not capable of
doing everything that you can do inside
of Novel crafter or pseudo write but it
is pretty good especially if you're just
starting out and Raptor write comes from
the future fiction Academy which is an
education platform and so you will
actually get a free course when you sign
up for Raptor Rite that will walk you
through how to use Ai and it's a
fantastic course I definitely recommend
checking it out if you want some
beginner instruction on how to use Ai
and then you can use Raptor write as you
are going through that instruction and
figure out how to do all of that so let
me just show you a little bit of what
Raptor write can do so the first thing
is now that I've done a more in-depth
video on Raptor write but the first
thing I want to highlight here is that
you can have different folders so you
can create a folder here and say like
this is going to be my characters okay
you add a folder and then you can create
so this one's just called blank title
it's in there by default you could say
okay this is my
character Jason and then you can fill in
information about the character Jason or
you can run the llm and the commands to
do so are down here so I can give it a
command like this and the window here
works as both a chat interface and a
place to put all your stuff so it's kind
of a combination of a lot of different
things that we've seen so far I can just
select this and then run the llm hit
submit and it's giving me a full
character profile of this character
named Jason and if I like that I can
confirm and now I have all of this
information and then the next thing I
could do let's say I go out of this
folder and I want to create a new folder
that's the chapters and then in here
we'll say this one is called chapter one
I can actually go through these folders
and determine which ones are actually
used in the prompting and which ones are
not so if I want this one turned on I
can come in here and say okay this one
is toggled on that means the chat is
going to remember it when we get to
writing the pros so now if I go to
Chapters I can say give me the opening
of a chapter with 500 words describing
Jason's horrible day and then all I have
to do is Select that and run the
llm and here it is going ahead and
writing it so it works very similar to
novel crafter but honestly it's a little
bit simpler if you don't know what
you're doing if you haven't gone through
the free course that future fiction
Academy provides you you might be a
little lost at first but once you figure
it out it's very simple it's very easy
to do and again I'm not going to go in
depth of all all of these tools I'm just
going to give you my primary
recommendations but Raptor Rite is
definitely a good one especially because
it's free now there are some
capabilities that it doesn't really have
in fact there are some things that I use
novel crafter for that novel crafter
just makes a lot easier than Raptor
right I'll give you one example so for
instance I can select large chunks of
text here and I have built in prompts
that do certain things and and sometimes
there are cases where I just want to
select massive amounts of text at once
run a prompt on it it spits out the
output then I select the next massive
chunk of text run the same prompt and
that's something that's not as easy to
do just from a workflow standpoint in
Raptor right but novel crafter makes it
really easy it's also something that is
not really easy to do inside of PSE
sudoite this is why novel crafter is one
of my favorites because it is very
versatile it can do lots of cool stuff
and makes the whole facilitation of it
the workflow process a lot easier that's
why it's my favorite so what's the
bottom line what is my recommendation
for all of these tools well as I've
mentioned I usually recommend one
chatbot and one specialist tool of the
chat Bots I'd pick one of the big three
it doesn't really matter too much which
one just whichever works better for you
with the specialist tools I would go
with either Raptor right or novel
crafter again novel crafter is my
favorite but it is more complex there's
if you are Tech person it might not be
best for you it also costs a little bit
more so you might want to go with raptor
right in that case and then if you're
actually using AI to write the first
draft of your book then I would take a
look at PSE sudoite specifically for
their fine-tuned Muse model which is can
be used specifically to write that first
draft I think it is the best but I would
not use sudoite for anything else other
than writing that first draft I would
instead use one of the other two for all
of my writing needs except for that
first draft process and that's my top
recommendation now if you are unfamiliar
with how to use Ai and all of the
different ways that AI can help you
because AI can do so much more than just
writing the pros of a book and many
authors think that's what we're using it
for but really AI can help you at any
step of the process I did a whole video
where I went through 75 different things
that AI can do for you as a writer
besides just writing the actual Pros so
go check that video out and I will see
you in the next one